sorgen wegen britischer corona mutation
nach dem ausbruch in einem krankenhaus
in berlin befürchten die behörden
weitere infektionen test pflicht vor der
einreise für alle die aus einem
hochrisiko gebiet nach deutschland
kommen gelten jetzt schärfere regeln und
härter wechselt aus trainer bruno
labbadia muss gehen die berliner sind in
der tabelle kräftig abgerutscht
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers in allen an diesem
sonntag zu zehn minuten nachrichten in
der zusammenfassung sport ist auch dabei
mit kristin otto volles programm genannt
wir wissen immer noch viel zu wenig über
die mutationen des virus wie gefährlich
sie tatsächlich sein können schon allein
deshalb steigt jetzt die sorge
insbesondere in berlin wo ein
krankenhaus komplett unter quarantäne
steht
rund 1500 beschäftigte sind betroffen
wegen der steigenden zahl von
infektionen dort mit der so genannten
britischen variante von corona mehr von
stefanie dosch wachpersonal vor dem
humboldt klinikum am nachmittag 400
patienten und 1700 mitarbeiter stehen
seit gestern grundsätzlich unter
quarantäne
neue patienten werden nicht mehr
aufgenommen für mindestens 14 tage
sie wollte nicht infizierte
klinikmitarbeiter befinden sich in so
genannter pendelt quarantäne dürfen nur
zur arbeit und zurück
mindestens 14 patienten und sechs
mitarbeiter hatten sich mit der
hochansteckenden virus mutation b 11 7
aus england infiziert die erste klinik
schließung dieser art in deutschland nun
werden alle patienten und mitarbeiter
durch getestet am heutigen tag ist es
schon so dass erste ergebnisse
eintrudeln
die uns nicht glücklich machen wir
werden im laufe der kommenden stunden
und des kommenden tages ein einigermaßen
besseren überblick haben hoffen wir es
ist aber schon jetzt abzusehen dass die
fallzahl steigt dabei gilt das humboldt
klinikum als vorbildlich seit anfang des
jahres testet man hier auf die mutation
als einzige klinik in berlin neben der
charité vorab screening von bereits
positiven tests gemacht haben ist uns
diese mutante aufgefallen und deswegen
können wir dementsprechend gut handeln
um die bevölkerung als auch die
mitarbeiten im klinikum und die
patienten zu schützen die sorge ist
trotzdem groß dass die virus mutation
sich unkontrolliert ausbreitet in berlin
und ganz deutschland um das virus
einzudämmen soll die einreise nach
deutschland stärker kontrolliert werden
seit mitternacht gelten für 25 länder
mit besonders hohen infektionszahlen
schärfere regeln zu diesem hoch
risikogebieten gehören etwa
urlaubsländer wie portugal spanien und
ägypten
außerdem die usa und auch das
nachbarland tschechien
wer aus diesen ländern kommt braucht
einen negativen corona test und muss
sich vor der einreise digital anmelden
volker dutschek jetzt mit den details
sonderkontrollen auf deutschlands
größtem flughafen
die beamten haben heute in frankfurt am
main vor allem rückkehrer aus
sogenannten hochrisiko gebieten in
visieren keinen test dabei hat hat er
noch die möglichkeit hier im
transitbereich einen test durchzuführen
wir würden diese person dann auch
begleiten und zu führen und überwachen
aber wenn sich diese person weigert
diesen test durchzuführen kann auch
nicht einreisen und wir würden ihn
zurückweisen müssen wie es in der
beamtensprache heißt das heißt die
einreise wurde verweigert werden und er
müsste mit dem nächsten flug oder dem
gleichen flug wieder zurückfliegen
in haftung genommen werden auch die
fluggesellschaften wenn sie nicht
bereits vor abflug kontrollieren ob
gültige corona tests vorliegen hier
drohen bußgelder von bis zu 25.000 euro
lange schlangen im grenzgebiet in
oberfranken pendler aus tschechien
müssen künftig alle zwei tage einen
negativen krohn attest vorlegen wenn sie
in bayern die grenze übertreten
das wird von der bundespolizei
stichprobenartig kontrolliert hunderte
versuchten den test auf deutscher seite
zu machen
die lange wartezeit
vielen im grenzgebiet zu schaffen drei
viermal pro woche zum test um hier dann
noch zwei stunden zu warten
das kann nicht sein schwierige
aussichten im kleinen grenzverkehr
zwischen 35.000 und 60.000 tschechien
fahren regelmäßig zur arbeit nach
deutschland
israel geht jetzt noch einen drastischen
schritt weiter alle flughäfen sollen von
morgen nach dran bis ende des monats für
ankommende und abfliegende passagiere
geschlossen werden
es werde nur wenige ausnahmen geben
sagte ministerpräsident benjamin
netanjahu
er wolle damit verhindern dass weitere
corona mutationen eingeschleppt werden
viel gewonnen wäre ja wenn es ein
wirksames medikament gegen kuwait 19
gäbe neu ist eine therapie mit
speziellen antikörper sie können
risikopatienten einen schweren
krankheitsverlauf ersparen
das entsprechende medikament aus den usa
ist jetzt eingekauft worden vom
bundesgesundheitsministerium für 400
millionen euro es ist in der eu noch
nicht zugelassen und darf nur in
spezialisierten kliniken angewendet
werden mit dem präparat war auch donald
trump behandelt wurden
die korona zahlen in deutschland sind
weiter zurückgegangen das robert koch
institut meldet 12 1257 neuinfektionen
binnen 24 stunden das sind 1600 25
weniger als vergangenen sonntag 349
menschen sind in verbindung mit dem
virus gestorben jetzt weitere wichtige
themen heute das war gestern eine der
größten demonstrationen seit jahren in
russland und die staatsmacht reagierte
mit grosser härte viele verletzte und
fast 3500 festnahmen
nach angaben von bürgerrechtlern in rund
100 städten in ganz russland hatten
anhänger des kreml kritikers alexej
nawalny für dessen freilassung
demonstriert
gleichzeitig protestierten viele offen
gegen russlands präsidenten wladimir
putin und sie kündigten weitere proteste
an
jetzt nach china wo elf verschüttete
bergleute gerettet worden sind sie
hatten nach einer explosion unter tage
zwei wochen lang in rund 600 meter tiefe
ausharren müssen
zehn weitere männer werden in der
goldmine noch vermisst einer wurde tot
geborgen
die bergwerke in china sind berüchtigt
immer wieder kommt es dort zu schweren
unfällen ulf röller auf diese goldminen
im osten chinas schaut das land vor den
augen der nation kämpfen seit zwei
wochen
rettungsteams um die 22 eingeschlossenen
minenarbeiter der moment der bergung die
augen sind verbunden zum schutz gegen
das tageslicht elf bergleute holen sie
aus mehr als 500 meter tiefe nach oben
das werden wir die schwerverletzten das
ist immer so bei grubenunglücken die
bergleute die wir später hochholen den
geht es meistens körperlich und seelisch
gut durch extra gebohrte
versorgungsschächte ließen die
rettungsteams medikamenten essen in die
tiefe ein minenarbeiter ist bereits
gestorben zu zehn fehlt bisher jeder
kontakt die staatsmedien inszenieren die
bergung als nationales ereignis denn
chinas gruben gelten als die
gefährlichsten der welt
jedes jahr kommen tausende kumpel ums
leben oft wegen schlechter
sicherheitsvorkehrungen
die freiwilligen helfer werden in den
medien gefeiert
als ich die bohrmaschine gesehen habe
habe ich gedacht ohne kran funktioniert
das nicht da bin ich mit meinem kran zum
helfen gekommen
am 10 januar hatte es die explosionen
der goldmine gegeben die umstände sind
bisher ungeklärt
die bürgermeisterin der stadt musste
zurücktreten weil sie die
rettungsarbeiten zu spät eingeleitet hat
in china und wir kommen jetzt zum sport
hier in der sendung christin wasser so
da ja erstmal fußball hertha bsc hat
sich von geschäftsführer michael preetz
und trainer bruno labbadia getrennt
als konsequenz nach der sportlichen
misere mit nur einem punkt in den
letzten vier spielen nun soll beim
tabellenvierzehnten ein neuer impuls
gesetzt werden
die ära preetz endet nach zwölf jahren
als sportchef schon seit langem aber
stand er in der kritik der teuerste
spieler kader der klubgeschichte und
doch nur abstiegskampf das bedeutet nach
neun monaten auch das aus für trainer
labbadia
zeit für große veränderungen wir wollen
einen neustart und wir haben jetzt einen
personellen neustart gezwungenermaßen
auf grund der sportlichen
herausforderung sportdirektor arne
friedrich übernimmt dabei zunächst die
aufgaben von preetz bei der nachfolge im
trainerjob ist eine übergangslösung mit
pal dardai wahrscheinlich ihn hatte
preetz 2009/10 aussortierte die bayern
münchen hat das erste sonntagsspiel der
bundesliga gewonnen 4 0 bei schalke 04
die bayern nun mit sieben punkten
vorsprung spitzenreiter vor
leipzig platz zwei für die deutschen
biathletinnen mit der staffel zum
weltcup abschluss in antholz
erst als schlussläuferin franziska preuß
beim letzten schießen zu wirklich wurde
zogen die russinnen vorbei im ziel hatte
das deutsche quartett zu dem auch
vanessa ins janina hettich und denise
herrmann gehörten als zweite elf
sekunden rückstand unterm strich wm
generalprobe geglückt und das gilt
ebenso für bobpilot francesco friedrich
den dominator des weltcup winters in den
eiskanälen der rekord weltmeister
entschied nach dem 2 1 triumph gestern
auch die königsdisziplin am königssee
für sich und seine crew für friedrich
den großen wie er respektvoll genannt
wird der insgesamt 50 weltcup erfolg den
gesamtsieg kann er nun kommen das
wochenende sichern und mehr wintersport
unter zdf sport de sogar dominator
was für ein wort vielen dank christian
dann gucken wir uns noch schnell das
wetter an da ist einiges dabei schnee im
süden weniger wolken im norden ein paar
schauer dort stattdessen die höchsten
temperaturen zwischen minus drei und
plus vier grad dienstag und mittwoch
bleiben somit schnee und schneeregen am
donnerstag wird es deutlich milder aber
auch nicht wirklich sonnig fernseh
wetter halt wir sehen uns auch morgen
schon wieder wenn sie mögen punkt 19 uhr
aber erst hat der kollege claus kleber
die lage dieser welt nachher im heute
journal um 21.45 von uns allen hier für
sie einen sehr angenehmen sonntagabend
zum beispiel mit berlin direkt und theo
koll hatte